thank you
hey everybody what's going on it's
Sunday it's the end of the weekend it's
winding down yeah yeah man
you know you you know Tom's about to lay
down some [ __ ] yeah
he's gonna tell a story
yesterday I was over to dab biker bar
had his big ass [ __ ] biker come in
and his his name's uh John all right
he's about six foot five six foot four
he's got this [ __ ] long looking beard
like that he's up here at the bar with
his wife and I'm [ __ ] running around
behind him and [ __ ] and he goes hey hey
what's all this
what's all this you're like he's gonna
mean that's my business ain't no beer
that's no kitty milk
I was like what yeah I'm gonna get you a
little saucer put milk in a little drink
out of salsa like a little kid that's
Kitty meal that's a kitty milk beer
Kitty milk
God started [ __ ] laughing
Kitty milk yeah candy milk well and
that's wrong with you that's my that's
that's my name now Kitty milk okay
[ __ ] candy milk well now that you
said it I'm gonna call you yeah sorry
sorry to tell you yeah that little kitty
milk that's what he called
that's really funny what he said yeah
Sam Sam uh my beard was not uh not uh
masculine and not manly enough yeah he's
saying that [ __ ] was effeminate it was
like something for little kitties to
drink out of milk out of the saucer yeah
but he has like a big long beard so why
does he feel the need to like [ __ ] on
other people because to me that like
that speaks of insecure and insecurity
he's just [ __ ] with me he started
laughing
you know yeah I don't know so that's my
story
Tom Kitty milk Ross that's where we go
I kind of like that name
Danny Rowling said milk mustache or
chocolate milk mustache
yeah so uh Young Sherlock Holmes you
guys I now had you ever seen this movie
you had never seen this yeah I saw it oh
you didn't okay yeah a long time ago but
I didn't remember anything about that
you didn't rubber the weird thing about
this is that I feel like despite all of
the talent behind this and despite the
fact that I saw this a million times
when I was growing up because it seemed
like it was on cable all the time
um it didn't really do all that well
like in the United States and I mean it
made its money back overseas but I don't
know I feel like a lot of people don't
really remember it which is really weird
because it's like a really good movie I
always thought I remembered it when I
saw it I was like oh yeah I remember
this one
and I remember not really liking it that
much when it came out
um seeing it now I was like man this is
like this is kind of like Indiana Jones
and she says wait that's Steven
Spielberg and I was like oh okay well he
produced it yeah and then I was like it
feels kind of like Indiana Jones a
little bit
and then and then I said it's also kind
of like it's almost kind of like a
prototype Harry Potter kind of a feeling
to it
um
it's a high quality movie you know it's
real well made I don't know who did the
score had a really good score it wasn't
John Williams but it was John
williams-esque yeah I can't remember I
thought it was score but yeah well I
kind of feel well it was amblin
entertainment like I said that was
Steven Spielberg's production company
and they usually used John Williams but
I don't think they used him in this
particular one but they wanted something
like John williamsy yeah to get that
same feel to it a lot of it was like
striking me to be kind of like um
kind of like Temple of Doom yeah it's
all those like a temple of doom like but
for a slightly younger audience but I
will say that I don't know not that much
of a younger audience because I had
actually forgotten
um I thought it's just kind of like a
kids but more like why a I don't want to
say it's like a kids movie but watching
it I had forgotten like there's that
there's some pretty like [ __ ] up and
like nightmarish imagery in this and
people do get like killed and [ __ ] like
that too which they took that pretty
chick wrapped up like a mommy and poured
hot wax on her and killed her I guess
you never yeah you never found out what
happened to her and spoiler alert too
like the main female character in this
Elizabeth she dies also she dies at the
end she gets she gets shot yeah like uh
you know sacrifices herself for uh for
homes or whatever so I just I don't know
and I feel like and it was a time period
too where I mean at least in the UK like
there was a really successful uh
Sherlock Holmes Show on I believe like
in this because this came out in 1985.
so I don't really see why I I don't know
I think this maybe would have flown more
nowadays the weird thing about it is
like back in the 80s when they were
thinking about doing this movie it was
very important to Steven Spielberg who
was producing Chris Columbus who wrote
the screenplay and also Barry Levinson
who directed it they were like really
really worried that
um Sherlock Holmes purists were gonna
get all over their [ __ ] for because this
is not a canonical
home story obviously like Halton Watson
didn't meet each other until they were
adults so this is kind of like going you
know it's not canon uh so they were like
afraid that you know people were gonna
get mad at them so they went really out
of their way to you know consult
different like homes experts and like
have the script go through like all this
kind of stuff and I think they even went
through like some of uh Arthur Conan
Doyle's like family of like living
family members like to make sure it was
okay with them and [ __ ] like that so
they really did try to be respectful of
the
of the character which I thought was
like actually pretty
um you know that was pretty admirable
but the weird thing about it is I feel
like something like this like a concept
like this would probably fly a lot
better nowadays you know what I'm saying
where people are used to seeing
fictional characters like put into
different situations that aren't exactly
like from The Source material so you
know I think you could probably do this
now and not because I think it has been
done now like Sherlock Holmes like in
weird other you know [ __ ] dimensions
and [ __ ] like that but I back in the 80s
I guess that wasn't really a thing that
you did so I don't know if that was
necessarily why people didn't respond to
it the same way that they responded to
other
films of this ilk but I don't know like
I said it's very much like Temple of
Doom it has like a very Temple of doomy
kind of uh storyline to it and like you
said it is like a Proto Harry Potter I
feel like well Chris Columbus obviously
he wrote uh did he direct the first two
Harry Potter movies I feel like so maybe
it could be the JK Rowling like saw this
movie I would imagine a lot of people
did
and maybe it gave her an idea because
this is a very very
Harry Potter vibe to it like boy School
uh the whole kind of you know and the
fact that it has not Supernatural but
because an aspect of the plot has to do
with like a hallucinogenic drug that
like this cult is using so they have um
an excuse to show these kind of like
[ __ ] up like nightmarish images in it
it's funny I've only seen the first
Harry Potter movie
um the first one is actually the books
are good I actually quite liked the
books I thought they were entertaining
the first movie is a little too
kid-focused the movie's got a lot better
once they got um once the kids got older
because and the books got better like
later on too because they got darker as
the kids grew up you know what I mean
yeah I saw it and I I wasn't impressed
when I saw the first movie but what I
liked more about the first movie is uh
later on they did a skit on Saturday
Night Live where they had the damn girl
from Harry Potter they're redoing here
about and she'd gotten implants remember
that and they had her in that real
low-cut thing they're trying to do Harry
Potter ripoff and every all the
characters are staring at her boobs
while she's talking remember no this is
[ __ ] hilarious man it was on Saturday
Night Live they were just kind of poking
fun on the fact that that girl from
Harry Potter to have a [ __ ] big rat
well it's like she really did actually
most of the actors first of all of the
actors from Harry Potter that were like
really really young when they first
started you know they were very young
like awkward little kids and all of them
like uh filled out nice they uh they
looked really good when they got older
so they were just kind of [ __ ] with
that didn't they um but yeah I thought
it was pretty good you know I I
remembered this I remember seeing this
and thinking it was okay but it didn't
stick with me you know uh it wouldn't it
didn't stick with me the way like uh
what year did this come out at 85 yeah
see it didn't stick with me the way
Indiana Jones did or something it's just
something about it I guess the the
the cast was too young
maybe I think it was cool I guess like I
said it was almost like a slightly y a
version because I guess the characters
were supposed to be like 16 17 years old
so they weren't kids kids right they
were like teenagers so and like I said I
was actually kind of surprised because I
had remembered that I saw this movie a
lot like in the 80s but I had forgotten
and I I kind of had a concept of it as
more
kids focused but seeing it again last
night I was like oh this is actually
like a lot more horror base than I
remembered it being it's hard to believe
this is 85. it seems a lot later doesn't
it it does seems like it's a lot later
seems like late 80s or early 90s it
looks fantastic it looks real good and
fun fact this was actually the first
movie this one right here that had an
entire CGI character that uh that
Stained Glass Knight that jumped out the
same glass window and like fought that's
the first time that that ever happened
that was industrial Light and Magic like
the guy that uh later did Pixar like
foreign Pixar was the guy that did the
animation on that and it still looks
good I think because it wasn't supposed
to look natural it was supposed to look
like a night that it jumped out was made
of stained glass and was like moving
around so it still looks really good and
murder Hornet pointed out he said the
pastry scene is the best that is also my
favorite scene where they um you know
the three main characters uh Holmes and
Watson Elizabeth they get shot with the
hallucinogen and then they go in this
cemetery and start having visions and
Elizabeth is actually really terrifying
she like she gets buried alive and all
of a sudden it's like [ __ ] up and
everything but uh Watson because the big
joke is that he's not fat but he's just
like a little bit dumpy so the funny
thing is he's always like stuffing his
face with like pastries and whatnot so
he has a hallucination that there's like
a little Bakery window and then like all
the little pastries like come to life
like they're little Muppet eyes like pop
up and like they start jumping on him
and cramming the cells in his mouth and
stuff and it was just and then later on
like when he's actually eating like a
cream horn or something he's like
talking to and it's like super funny but
it's like I don't know why it was that I
always thought that was really funny but
it's also like kind of creepy and
disturbing because seriously what if you
were tripping on LSD or something and
you went like past a bakery shop and
like all the [ __ ] pastries came to
life that would you would [ __ ] freak
out so it kind of reminded me of that
but yeah so the story behind this like I
said is that
um you know this was actually directed
by Barry Levinson who I don't think had
done anything like this prior I mean he
did Diner he did the natural he did good
morning Vietnam which I love that movie
uh Bugsy Wag the Dog uh rain man so it
doesn't really seem like he would
normally do this kind of movie but I
think he did a good job on it and like I
said Chris Columbus wrote it obviously
he wrote The Goonies and Gremlins and
directed home alone and Mrs Doubtfire
and all that kind of stuff and um so
I kind of like uh you were asking the
the guy that plays the kid that plays uh
Sherlock Holmes in this yeah
um Nicholas Rowe and he's actually been
in a [ __ ] ton of stuff since then he's
been on a ton of British British TV he
was in a ton of movies he was actually
in Lock Stock and Two Smoking Barrels
which I totally forgotten about that's a
great movie by the way and he was also
in Seed of Chucky like one of the
Child's Play movies uh he's been in
other movies too the funny thing though
is that he actually played
a version of Sherlock Holmes but older
obviously in 2015 there was a movie with
sir Ian McAllen that was called Mr
Holmes and he played like a version of
Sherlock Holmes in that so I thought
that was kind of funny that they like
made a nod to that but yeah this has
like a ton of really famous British
actors in it there's a great video on
YouTube that I was watching earlier
today where the girl was talking about
all of the she called it six degrees of
Sherlock Holmes like all the British
actors that were in this movie that had
been in other Sherlock Holmes
adaptations or like had something to do
with other Sherlock Holmes adaptations
so that's like a really interesting
thing to watch if you're like interested
in that kind of stuff but I just kind of
liked the whole you know homes being at
boarding school and then Watson comes
there and then they befriend one another
and then basically they uncover this
plot that has to do with well first it
just seems like a bunch of weird
suicides but Holmes thinks duel that
they were probably murdered but the cops
don't want to know but so he starts like
investigating and it turns out that
there's this like weird Osiris
worshiping cult that they go around and
like the the person that's like their
assassin essentially they have like this
blue pipe and they go around like
hitting their targets like with this
hallucinogen and then the hallucinogen
usually causes them to like commit
suicide or die in an accident you know
what I mean like they'll jump out a
window or you know throw themselves in
front of a carriage because they can't
see what they're doing you know so uh so
they do that kind of stuff and like I
said their whole thing is they've been
kidnapping girls and wrapping them in
mummy rapping and put taking them down
in this big [ __ ] Temple that they
have which that Temple set's Amazing by
the way it still looks fantastic all the
costumes look great kind of like an
Egyptian version of template Doom kind
of yeah it's very very similar it's like
it doesn't have the whole like ripping
hearts out and stuff but it definitely
has hey we're making living girls into
mummies like I said they lay they wrap
them all up and they drug them and then
they wrap them all up in lay them and
then they pour like hot wax like hot
paraffin like on top of them and kill
them like that so it's pretty [ __ ] up
yep it's pretty [ __ ] up and like I
said because it has that whole plot
thread of the hallucinogen
um then it has an excuse to like show
these kind of like crazy uh
hallucinations there's actually like one
sequence in there too that was a little
bit like kind of reminded me of like Ray
harryhausen you know what I mean like
where the one guy was in the antique
shop and he saw like these little
gargoyle things that started like flying
around like all over him and stuff so I
don't know I just really like that I
think at the time
this didn't really get very good reviews
and I think it was because I mean Ebert
liked it but he was like um he's like
it's a little weird seeing like a
Sherlock I don't think people were used
to seeing a Sherlock Holmes story which
is supposed to be like very grounded and
logical that had these like weird like
Fantastical elements in it and I think
people were weirded out by that like I
said it's not weird nowadays because now
they do all kind of crazy [ __ ] like in
Crossovers and everything but I think
like back in the 80s people weren't
really used to seeing that maybe that's
what it was also remember back in the
80s there was a lot of Sherlock Holmes
stuff out on television and on cable
yeah and it tended to be dry and boring
so I think
trying to bring Sherlock Holmes to the
big screen and something kind of like a
young Indiana Jones type setting
I think it was kind of hard to make
Sherlock Holmes cool I think in the 80s
it's just maybe yeah maybe that's what
it was It was kind of to I remember
thinking that was kind of some nerdy
[ __ ]
that's some nerdy [ __ ] right there said
young Tom yeah
see that dude yeah he reads books and
[ __ ] yeah see I wasn't bothered by that
kind of thing because I was kind of
nerdy a nerdy [ __ ] yeah I think that's
what it was is it so that didn't bother
me no it would have been better if they
had made this an Indiana Jones movie
well Indiana and everything they did
well didn't they do young Indiana Jones
Chronicles that was a show it wasn't
Rivers
how to put Harrison Ford in that
[ __ ] made it an Indiana Jones
movie
yep
and Cat you could kept you could have
kept a lot of the story the same with
the poison I mean pretty much yeah I
mean this is essentially like a similar
like Adventure type story
and you'd had an adult in there with a
gun and a whip and a hat and you could
have uh you you so you now have
plausibility for bigger uh bigger action
scenes and it's not in the Victorian era
it's like in it's like in the the 40s
late 40s or the 50s something like that
it would have worked I think
yeah but I mean they already had Indiana
Jones though I can see how they were
trying to go a different way with it and
maybe skew a little slightly younger it
would have made money though yeah I mean
this did make money but not in the U.S
like in the US I think it just made its
money back but then like overseas like
it made more money Jeffy art said I
watched this movie in school before
Christmas break in the fifth grade it
was my Gateway into the mythology of
Sherlock Holmes that and the episode of
Star Trek uh the Next Generation
Elementary deer data oh I remember that
one I like your little monocle guy there
too I've never seen that that emoji
before uh then Jeff yard said I wonder
if a factor could have been that the
Victorian setting didn't make the
mainstream appeal in the 1980s it could
have been that it could have been that
because I do kind of feel like the 80s
all of the movies that were iconic from
the 80s I feel like very few of them
were period pieces unless I'm thinking
well I guess Indiana Jones was but sort
of I don't think the Victorian era was
the problem because then you just look
just look at Harry Potter it has that
feel to it it looks like this movie even
though Harry Potter is the modern day
even though Harry Potter but it's still
you know I mean when they're in these
weird [ __ ] schools and [ __ ] it looks
kind of Victorian and their outfits kind
of look a little bit Victorian
but they've added magic to it yeah I'm
[ __ ] flying brooms and [ __ ] and that
sold like hotcakes
because it did yeah it could more action
and stuff matter of fact I didn't just
see the first one I saw the other one it
was like a it was like a spin-off
remember we saw it in a theater we
reviewed it oh yeah
um some bad guys I think that was
Fantastic Beasts yeah that's kind of
yeah that's like a like crimes at
Grindelwald or whatever yeah that's like
that's like an offshoot it's like yeah
it was like that which I didn't read
those I read I read the Harry Potter
books but I haven't read any of the
extra canonical and I'm in a theater
full of these damn [ __ ] nerds and
[ __ ] they're all dressed up I have no
idea about any of this well now see I
didn't read any of those I didn't read
any of the Fantastic Beasts books yeah
but it was an enjoyable movie it was all
right but I didn't really know I had no
idea what was going on right I knew who
some of the characters were but that's
about it just watching it I was like
whatever yeah I was just saying it's
like oh yeah I think it's not the guy
that's like the dad of that other guy or
something like that yeah they're all
oohing and on like they know these
characters well they do they yeah yeah I
know they're just saying you know
they're all ooh and on and I'm like oh
yeah like I said I'm a lot more familiar
with the Harry Potter Universe because
I've actually read all of those
um but you know this and it's just
interesting to me and I had forgotten
too because it was interesting to me how
Harry Pottery this movie it is it is
very Harry Pottery like because and even
[ __ ] the kid uh that plays Watson uh
even kind of looks like Harry Potter
like he's got the glasses and the hair
and it's just it's a very hairy Pottery
kind of story and there's like even
three of them it's two two boys and a
girl you know and they're they're kind
of like personalities aren't exactly the
same it's not the same quite the same
Dynamic see it wasn't the Victorian look
that held this back I don't think Harry
Potter and how it has that same look it
did well yeah Harry Potter would have
done well in 85 I think yeah could have
done real well
it didn't get written until much later
but I think so I'm kind of feeling that
maybe JK Rowling was used well I don't
know if it's so much that because I
think I don't even know if it's so much
like a rip-off like Harry Potter
Universe being a ripoff of this I think
it's just so much that the whole
boarding school culture in the UK like
the whole school culture
um it kind of lends itself to that sort
of entertainment so I don't even know if
stuff I mean I'm not from I you know
I've lived in the UK for a little while
but you know I'm not from there
originally so I don't know if maybe it's
just that's just part of the British
school culture and so that's why stuff
like that keeps coming out in movies and
it's not necessarily that one thing is
ripping off the other thing but I mean
there are some shots in this like
particularly the one shot
um where all the boys are like at dinner
and obviously like this is you know it's
by candlelight because it's a Victorian
era it's not magic like in the Harry
Potter when it's like all these like
floating candles and it's all like
magicy and [ __ ] but it's very similar
like the way it's shot you know what I'm
saying like you can tell that I know
that Chris Columbus didn't direct this
but he did write it and he did direct
the first two Harry Potter movies so you
can definitely see the connection there
you know what I mean it is very much
like that and even though this doesn't
have quote-unquote magic in it it does
have pollution hallucinations in it and
it does have like a lot of horror
imagery like I said because especially
um when I think the scariest one is like
Elizabeth's
um
her hallucination because like I said it
happens it's almost like a [ __ ] uh
Ebenezer Scrooge you know Ghost of
Christmas future kind of [ __ ] going on
and it's like pretty like with a [ __ ]
dead zombie like Skeleton thing like you
know carving her name into a headstone
and [ __ ] like that which I thought was
like so [ __ ] cool like back in the
80s because I love that kind of [ __ ]
yeah Danny's requesting uh The Haunting
episode Echoes from the grave now did we
do that one that one we did it I thought
we did that one if we I'll check and if
we did if we didn't then we'll do that
one yeah but if uh maybe we can do the
[ __ ] crazy one and put the hook and
mummy what about the Bobby yeah we need
to save one for Halloween okay yeah
we'll save that but I mean like I said
we can do because like I said next next
uh Monday is Halloween so we can do like
an episode of a haunting but we can also
just kind of do like a regular or Side
Tracks Halloween special type thing you
know just all together so I'm not too
worried about it I guess it'll be sort
of freewheeling
um but I thought we had done Echoes from
the grave though we can check
I'm gonna have to go back and check I
mean I'm pretty sure that we did that
maybe maybe not I know that I know that
title I just can't remember which if we
made that joke like a million times it's
like their titles titles are all about
the same I picture which one is that you
know those like they used I don't know
if they still sell these or not but they
used to have those little box sets you
could buy them at bookstores and stuff
and it was kind of like called the
magnetic poem set or whatever and it
would just have like all these different
words like on little magnets and you put
them on your fridge and you could
rearrange them like to make uh poems
with I kind of feel like there's a
haunting specific box of that and then
they just have a fridge in the break
room at the haunting production company
and they just keep moving it around it's
just like this one says grave and death
and Demon and blah blah they just like
move the [ __ ] hidden words around you
know what I mean
yeah Robbie Coltrane died that sucks
yeah he's awesome I loved him I don't
remember who that was you'd know him if
you saw him he's been in a million
things uh Danny Rowling says uh Gary
Oldman and David thulis cast as
werewolves in the third Harry Potter
Prisoner of Azkaban was a great idea
yeah I think after the third one like
they got much better because I mean the
books too because
um you know once it got into like the
[ __ ] Dementors and all that kind of
stuff like that was like super scary and
that was like way better than because
the first couple movies like I said they
were still kids so they couldn't do
anything like too [ __ ] crazy but once
they got older and they were getting to
like 17 18 years old then like people
were like getting [ __ ] killed left
and right and they I mean the Harry
Potter book say what you will about them
but they did have a pretty high body
count like a bunch of people got [ __ ]
killed in that [ __ ] and some of this
stuff was like super super scary
um Danny Rowling said you did Echoes
from the past recently but I don't know
that you did Echoes from the grave okay
so maybe that's what it is I'm thinking
of Echoes from the past and then there's
a different one called Echoes from the
grave
right so okay so I don't remember which
one Echoes from the grave well I don't
either but that's well like I said
that's what we were saying we don't like
know we don't know but it echoes from
the ground
[Laughter]
no that's my ass is haunted yeah well to
say notes
it's a sequel It's the sequel yeah you
think I'm kidding but she did actually
make a porno movie called
like
[Laughter]
oh my God it goes from your ass that's
like my ass is empty you know yeah
that's kind of gross yeah oh my God yeah
they'd make a movie about that though
well yeah I kind of feel like they make
a movie about anything as far as porn is
concerned they don't have rule 34 for
nothing yeah but yeah so
um I was actually like this is uh Young
Sherlock Holmes is actually on YouTube
for free with ads so if you've never
seen it or if you have saw it like a
long time ago when you were a kid you
know and you want to see it again I
would recommend like watching it again
because it was actually I remembered it
being really good but it was actually
much better than I remembered and it
aged really well I think like this
special effects still look good
um the [ __ ] costumes really look the
sets look really good it's a because Tom
was watching he's like man this is a
classy flick and I was like yeah it is a
classy flick and like I said it's got
tons and tons of like really well-known
British character actors in it and I
don't know I just thought it was always
like I always thought it was a cool
movie and it just
baffled me that I mean I didn't know at
the time because I saw it on cable I
don't think I saw this theater
um I didn't know at the time that it
wasn't like super super successful or
that it wasn't all that critically
because I don't really care about that
but when I was like reading about it now
they said yeah it didn't really do all
that well like it didn't get [ __ ] on or
anything but people were just kind of
like meh
um and I just wondered why because all
of everybody involved in this like all
of their other [ __ ] was like super super
successful so production quality is
about like in Indiana Jones movie it is
it's a top-notch movie
that's what I'm saying yeah so I don't I
don't really know and it's weird too
because I feel like movies of this kind
and from this era it seems like every
single one of them
has like a cult following and I don't
know if this one does I mean I'm sure it
does but I don't think it has like the
same huge cult following as some other
80s movies from this area like The
Goonies or something like that there was
a lot of Goonies Vibe of this in a way
it's like more serious well it's the
same writer it's the same writer yeah as
you know that wrote The Goonies but
obviously this is Victorian era and not
modern day but you can tell that it was
kind of like and I think too the script
because Chris Columbus is American
obviously but um the script was like run
through a British
novelist like to make it sound British
you know what I mean because
you sometimes you see that because
I've seen well I've seen it like the
other way too but a lot of times if you
have a British writer who's writing an
American movie or vice versa like
sometimes it'll be fine but then they'll
use this really odd turn of phrase that
a real American and or British person
wouldn't use and then you're like oh a
British person wrote this because an
American person wouldn't say that but at
least on this one they did have the
wherewithal to kind of run it through a
British guy like a novelist and a
Sherlock Holmes expert like to make sure
that it was copacetic and that it was
all Canon you know what I mean well at
least as Canon as it could be and even
at the beginning and the end it had like
messages like yeah we realized this
isn't based on Arthur Conan Doyle's work
it's based on his characters and stuff
but you know this is just like a fun
respectful kind of outside thing that
we're doing so we just hope you enjoy it
blah blah so they really did take pains
too
not offend anybody I guess because you
know those Sherlock Holmes fans would
just get gather up their pitchforks and
[ __ ] like that
uh Danny Rowling said we should do the
Night Flyer for Tuesday
uh we might although
did I look for it and I found it hard to
find I was gonna do that or I might do
that George Romero movie Bruiser that
one of you guys mentioned which I had
never even heard of because I saw that
was free somewhere too
and I was like so we might do that or we
could do the night player too if I can
find it
it's on YouTube did somebody put it on
YouTube like legally illegally I'm not
really sure
oh and Pat Hatfield yeah I wanted to
mention this too um this movie could
have also been the first or at least one
of the first examples of an after credit
sequence yeah I think this might have
I'm I'm sure there was one earlier than
this but yeah if you're watching this
movie watch all the way it's just like
it's a Marvel it's like a Marvel movie
because you have to watch all the way to
the end of the credits there's a little
Easter egg at the end and it was kind of
like setting up
a sequel because the thing about it was
that even though in the US this is
called Young Sherlock Holmes uh in the
UK and in other countries it was called
Young Sherlock Holmes and the Pyramid of
fear so it's clear that if this was
successful they were thinking of making
it a series and the fact that it had
that after credit sequence like
introducing Moriarty essentially like
the main big bad
um you know it seemed like they were
trying to set up a series but because it
didn't do as well as they hoped then
that never happened but I kind of feel
like you could do a reboot of this
nowadays although maybe people are sick
of Charlotte because I think what is
there like five Sherlock Holmes [ __ ]
shows on right now played out yeah I
mean people are still watching them so I
guess like they like it but I think
there's a couple British ones there's a
couple American ones there's there's
another there's an interdimensional one
you know what I mean that it's like
comedies that failed well that was
terrible that was a terrible anyway that
was a terrible movie uh Pat Hatfield
said I agree the Night Flyer is great
okay well I'll look for that then I'll
look for that then like I said I was
thinking about doing Bruiser the George
Romero but
uh if I can find night flare we'll do
that instead but tomorrow we're gonna do
a haunting and I guess we're gonna do
Echoes from the grave not Echoes from I
haven't done it right yeah I think well
he said we've done actors in the past
but I'll look I'll look okay if we
haven't done it you can't Google it you
can't find it on the search then we
guess we didn't do it yeah we don't know
we don't remember yeah we don't know we
can't remember all this we don't know
what we're doing at the time obviously
it's just such a ramshackle operation
that's all right though all right so
we're gonna wrap it up for today because
man I did not get much sleep last night
I'm gonna exhausted although I got a lot
done today I got like three or four
videos done today so I'm kind of proud
of myself but uh you wet and I gotta put
the garbage out tonight that's right
I forgotten next time yeah somebody
somebody said like because I'm on the
little you know uh Blackberry Reserve
yeah neighborhood board yeah they said
that nobody had collected their garbage
for seven weeks no [ __ ] I'm like where
the [ __ ] you live do they live in this
neighborhood they came and got the
garbage the other day didn't they maybe
they're at the end of a road or
something and the uh uh the truck is
missing because I was like maybe seven
weeks of garbage just piling up I guess
I was like maybe they just don't like
you yeah yeah okay I don't remember
going seven weeks and then not picking
the garbage up I would have noticed oh
of course that's what I'm saying I mean
I just went out I just went out there
like the other day and put a bag in
there and it wasn't even full so it's
like they must have been here yeah I
don't know but it's I'm like what I
don't know where that person lives they
said they're supposedly live in this
neighborhood but I don't know like where
what part of this neighborhood they live
at maybe they like live behind something
and they keep missing their house I
don't know but yeah so
uh have a good rest of your weekend you
guys and we'll be back tomorrow doing a
haunting and uh so just be sure to drop
by then and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow bye